in our morning rounds they look at
dramatic disparities in drug prices are
continuing bill of the month partnership
with Kaiser health news and NPR examines
unexpected medical costs today we're
highlighting one father's fight to get
his daughter the hormone blocker
medicine she needs for the right price
he was stunned to learn the drug costs
eight times more when used for children
than for adults
last summer Sudeep in Saratov Sally
started to notice something different
about their daughter she was developing
a lot faster than what seemed
appropriate now eight years old she's
already taller than her 12 year old
brother just started to get the changes
that you typically see for an older
child doctors diagnosed her with central
precocious puberty a rare condition that
causes early puberty and can stunt
natural growth into adulthood doctors
recommended a proven treatment some form
of medication would be given to
basically stop the hormone pulsing that
was causing her to have early puberty
so basically kind of turning off that
switch an implant placed under the skin
turns off that switch every day it
releases low doses of a hormone blocker
Tok Sally researched the two implants
available to his daughter
one option supreme' in LA is a treatment
fda-approved specifically for children
with central precocious puberty an
implant for one year has a staggering
price tag 37 thousand three hundred
dollars a cheaper option ventus has a
list price of four thousand four hundred
dollars it's the exact same hormone
blocker with slightly lower doses but
it's FDA approved only for late stage
prostate cancer both drugs are made by
the same manufacturer endo
pharmaceuticals in a statement endo said
they are FDA approved for two unique
indications appropriate only for that
particular patient population I'm
looking at this big Hoss difference for
no clinical reason doctors we spoke to
say the cheaper drug is just as
effective in children so tucks Olly
wanted his daughter to get the less
expensive option but his insurer
UnitedHealthcare would only approve the
more expensive drug leaving the family
with a higher out-of-pocket cost but for
this
father the problem goes far beyond money
I feel like the patient consumer is
completely blind and I think it's just
to me like kind of morally reprehensible
you're taking a predatory stance on
families in need
United Healthcare told CBS News in a
statement quote our coverage policies
are aligned with FDA regulations and
ventus is not fda-approved to treat
central precocious puberty when the
provider expressed concern over the cost
of soup rel in LA we worked with them to
allow for coverage of Ventus dr.
Elizabeth Rosenthal editor-in-chief of
kaiser Health News is here doctor good
morning I don't I don't think people can
understand and I want to know the reason
why two drugs with the very same
underlying active ingredient are two
different prices well the simple answer
is because drug makers can do this they
apply to the FDA for different purposes
using the same active ingredient and
they call it two different drugs but it
is the same drug it's almost a $30,000
price difference you're saying they do
that because they can they do that
because they can so they're they're
approved for different conditions and
that's why sometimes insanely somewhat
your insurer will say well we'll approve
the more expensive one but not the
cheaper one we know how much the family
ended up paying for the less expensive
drug well these things come in bundles
so you get it and you know you get it
implanted so they ended up paying about
twelve thousand dollars for the implant
which they were told with all fees would
have been closer to a hundred thousand
if they use the approved pediatric
version even though they were basically
the same thing no sir nothing consumers
can do because I like what you said
insanely because it does sound insane
yeah well this consumer happens to be
lucky because he was a physician and
said whoa so I think what what normal
people should do is ask there ya know is
who don't have that background
ask your doctor is there something
cheaper sometimes you know this is an
extreme example the the adult dose may
be cheaper than the pediatric sometimes
it may be you've been prescribed a 500
milligram pill which is expensive but
the 250 milligrams is really cheap so
you could just take two of those so
always ask
price of a drummer the doctors obligated
to tell you that there is a cheaper
option they should you know they should
be looking out for you they're not
making money from these drug sales so
they should be looking out for patient
was be nice if they could make this
easier for folks right I mean this is oh
you know that's my mantra why do we have
to call it investigative journalists or
do research in order to just do the
right thing get the best price by the
way how was his daughter doing she's
doing great she got the implant in late
January and she's thriving and they're
already seeing some good effects so it
all worked out well for this family
because the dad when we are to do who
aren't doctors so what should we do ask
a doctor it's a cheaper version of the
same drug that would work just as well
and often there is I didn't know if
you're right yeah well but we'll be back
with another bill next month and let's
supply thank you thank you or thank
thank you doctor